bonsoir thierry lebreton merci de
répondre à nos questions est ce qu'il
faut craindre une quatrième nuit
d'émeutes ce soit ça avait commencé
samedi
est-ce que ça va crescendo ou pas il ya
une vraie inquiétude vous l'avez noté on
peut pas savoir ce qui va se passer mais
c'est surtout effectivement
l'instauration du couvre-feu sa vie
dernier qui était finalement le
déclencheur de ces de ces violences qui
reste quand même relativement limité
tout de même mais elles sont nouvelles
dans le pays et c'est pour ça que ça
choque le premier ministre marque route
dit que 99% des néerlandais soutiennent
les mesures restrictives de liberté pour
lutter contre le courant navires us
comment alors expliquer cette colère qui
sont les 1 % restants qui sont là les
manifestants leur profil c'est quoi
c'est vrai d'abord qu'il ya un vrai
soutien massif finalement à la coalition
gouvernementale même si elle et lucio
nerfs ce qui effectivement on réagit et
ses problèmes en des jeunes qui sont
évidemment eux mêmes aussi très
impactées par par les mesures ou en tout
cas par la situation depuis des mois
entiers on les a pas entendus finalement
ces jeunes et donc pour eux c'est
probablement à un moyen de 2 serait de
se faire entendre de manière violente et
donc d'où la réaction effectivement très
unanime de la classe politique pour bien
sûr sur ce s'indigner sur ses fonctions
ces violences évidemment audet de
s'indigner le premier ministre mark
rutte
qu'est ce qui pourrait faire
prochainement pour faire face à ces
violences et il pourrait changer de
politique
faire volte-face revenir sur
l'instauration du couvre-feu
effectivement c'est probablement la
mesure qui a été déclenché aux mais je
pense pas qu'il va revenir dessus parce
que d'abord encore une fois il ya un
soutien massif de l'opinion à l'ensemble
de ces mesures
donc c'est tout simplement peut-être
faire effectivement faire preuve de
fermeté mais aussi toujours autres l
écoute de ses jeunes
et puis tout simplement continuer à
parler à agir et à dialoguer avec toutes
les parties
on rentre dans une période un peu
délicate puisque finalement les
élections nationales auront lieu dans un
peu plus d'un an dans moins de deux mois
maintenant effectivement à la mi mars
donc les choses se vont se précipiter un
petit peu
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
situation de violence ce qu'elle
pourrait intervenir par exemple en
france
en cas de troisième confinement par
exemple je ne sais pas si les choses
sont comparables et les violences dont
on parle effectivement sont aussi
peut-être pas aussi importante qu'on en
parle
en france c'est vrai que beaucoup de
villes ont été impactées et sait pas
quelles sont elles sont pas négligeables
mais peut-être que l'ampleur qu'on en
donne est peut-être moins important donc
je ne peux pas non plus comparer avec ce
qui se passe en france aussi on regarde
un peu ce qui se passait dans le passé
c'est souvent effectivement en marche
d'autres sujets de mécontentement comme
par exemple ceux des gilets jaunes mais
non ça ne peut pas vous répondre
par rapport à ces violences qui ont eu
lieu aux pays-bas vite que beaucoup de
villes sont impactés quelle ville
exactement on parle évidemment
d'amsterdam c'est david la plus connue
est ce que d'autres villes comme
rotterdam eindhoven là c'est pas un beau
ping'an sont impactés toutes les
vieilles c'est cette fois le profil des
ddd ville les villes urbaines entre
guillemets ou plus rurales non ce sont
aussi des villes qui sont moins dans le
centre des pays bas comme un symbole par
exemple ou à eindhoven où vous l'avez
évoqué mais celle qui a marqué les
esprits français si rotterdam
effectivement où il ya une concentration
de cherré de deux jeunes qui à qui on
fait un sport ou des gares donc
retourner bien sûr à madame également où
elle et les grandes villes n'est pas
vraiment profil filmant les commerçants
sont maintenant fermés subissent les
fracas des manifestants est ce que c'est
une double peine pour eux dans quel état
d'esprit ils sont les commerçants
néerlandais ils ne sont pas surtout
habitué à ce genre de manifestations et
de violences donc évidemment ils sont
ils sont ils sont choqués comme je crois
l'ensemble de la population
et comme ce fut le cas d'ailleurs en
france on peut l'imaginer
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
tirer le breton je rappelle que vous
êtes le pré sident le président de
l'association français des pays bas